دخلت صحيفه واشنطن بوست عن مسؤولين
امريكيين قولهم ان واشنطن تحث اوكرانيا
سرا على الانفتاح على المحادثات مع روسيا
واضافت الصحيفه ان الهدف من هذه الخطوه
ليس دفعه اليد للتفاوض بل لضمان محافظه
اوكرانيا على دعم دول
تطاول امد الحرب ولتخفيف الضغط على اداره
بيضا في هذه المرحله بسبب تعهدها
بالاستمرار في دعم اوكرانيا
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الاعزاء كان ذاك خبر
حلقتنا ولنا في نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات الى اي
حد تعكس هذه الخطوه مستوى الضغوط التي
تتعرض لها واشنطن وكياده بسبب اعلان
القياده الاوكرانيه رفض التفاوض مع روسيا
في ظل وجود بوتين
وما امكانيه استجابه اوكرانيا للطلب
الامريكي باعلان الانفتاح على تفاوض مع
روسيا وعلى اي نحو يمكن ان ترد موسكو على
مثل هذه الخطوه
وما هي المالات المحتمله للحرب الروسيه
على اوكرانيا في ضوء مواقف الاطراف
الفاعله من مسار التفاوض بشان انهائها
[موسيقى]
في خبر رفض مجلس الامن القومي في البيت
الابيض تاكيده او رفضه
وعلقت عليه الخارجيه الامريكيه بالطعن في
جديه روسيا في التفاوض مع اوكرانيا
واشنطن بوست عن مسؤولين امريكيين ان
الولايات المتحده تحث اوكرانيا سرا في هذه
المرحله على اعلان الاستعدادها للتفاوض مع
روسيا
صحيفه اوضحت ان المسؤولين الامريكيين لا
يهدفون بذلك للضغط على اكياس من اجل دفعها
الى المفاوضات بل لضمان ان تحافظ اوكرانيا
على دعم دول
تخشى تاجيج الحرب لسنوات قادمه
واشارت الصحيفه الى ان رفضه
مع روسيا في ظل وجود بوتن وضع اداره في
موقف صعب
بسبب تعهد واشنطن بتقديم المساعدات
لاوكرانيا لاطول فتره ممكنه
كما انه تسبب في قلق دول في اوروبا
وافريقيا وامريكا اللاتينيه تشعر بالاثر
الاكبر لتبعات الحرب من حيث تكلفه الغذاء
والوقود
رغم اتفاق المسؤولين الامريكيين كما تقول
الصحيفه مع مباراههم الاوكرانيين على ان
بوتين ليس جادا في الوقت الحالي بشان
المفاوضات
[موسيقى]
لمناقشه هذا الموضوع امانه
وزير الخارجيه الاوكرانيه الصادق ومن
واشنطن معنا السفير ويليام كورتيني مساعد
الرئيس بيل كلينتون لشؤون روسيا واوكرانيا
والبحث في مؤسسه ترامب للدراسات ومن موسكو
معنا ايلينا سبونينا الباحثه والمحلل
السياسيه الروسيه وابدا معك سيد قسطنطينيه
من اي زاويه او كيف يمكن لاوكرانيا ان
تفهم هذا الطلب
الامريكي بان تبدي على الاقل في الظاهر ان
تبدي اوكرانيا مرونه حيل التفاوض مع روسيا
كما تعلمون
انه في البدايه الحرب التي شنتها روسيا
بشكل غير متوقع
اي
استفزاز من
اوكرانيا
لكن اصبح واضحا بعد فتره قصيره بان الشرطه
الوحيد اللي تقبله روسيا هو الاستسلام
الكامل من قبل اوكرانيا
وهم يريدون ان تقبل ذلك
بعد فتره قصيره الرئيس اوكرانيا وحكومه
اوكرانيا
المشتركه لابد ان تكون لابد القانون
الدولي هو ان سلامه اراضيها وسياده
الثانيه كلها
طيب اذا توفرت هذه الشروط لا ديسناك مشكله
في التفاوض حول طريقه قبول سحب القوات
الروسيه من العراق
عفوا سيد قسطنطين المشكله ليست هنا يعني
المشكله هي في الموقف
المرتفع السقف الذي حددته كياف تقول كيد
انها لا تريد التفاوض مع وجود بوتن هذا
الامر قد يشعر الولايات المتحده بالحرج
وقد يشعر ايضا تلك الدول التي تدعم
اوكرانيه بالحرج على اعتبار انه سقف مرتفع
جدا هل لك ان تنزل عن هذا السقف وتقبل
بالتفاوض مع بوتن
ليس هناك
يمكن تسمح بتغير الموقف
والمقاربه الذي للحكومه الالكترونيه
لو كان هناك اي عنصر جديد هل لو ان فوتي
نوافقه
[موسيقى]
بانه
ولو قال انه
سحب القواته فانا شخصيا وانا هنا لا اتحدث
نيابه حكومه انا شخصيا
لعدم الحديث
ولكن لم يشهد لحد الان اي مؤشر بان روسيا
غيرت موقعها في ما يتعلق باساسيه
وبالتالي فالموضوع ليست رغبته الثانيه
بالتفاوض بل هي الموضوع هو رغبته وافقت
روسي على قبول الشروط التي تؤدي الى انه
اي نوع مفاوضات سيد ويليام ااا كورتي الى
اي مدى هذا الموقف يشعر الولايات المتحده
بالحرج
وخصوصا ان هذا يعني
ربما يطيل امد الحرب والولايات المتحده
وحلفائها ايضا مضطره للدعم طويل الامد
لاوكرانيا معنى لهذا الدعم من تكلفه كبيره
على الحكومات وشعوبها
حاليا هذا ليس الوقت المناسب للمتعوض
السفير هيرشكا محيط بقوله ان روسيا غير
راغبه بالتفاوض حول انسحاب قواتها اطلاقا
اوكرانيا تنتصر في ساحات المعارض
واوكرانيا ستواصل على الارجح
اراضي جديده على في ساحه المعركه وبالتالي
من السابق الاواني الحديث عن الفوضات رئيس
ولكن
التفاوض الان الان ونحن لا نتحدث الان
هناك يعني فرصه للتفاوض و همم هناك من
يدعو للمفاوضات بالمعنى الحقيقي نحن نتحدث
عما يطلبه او تطلبه الاداره الامريكيه من
اظهار مرونه في هذا الموضوع من اجل ضمان
الدعم الدول لاوكرانيا هل هذا وهذا كان
سؤالي سيد ويليام هل هذا يعبر عن حرج ما
تعيشه اداره الرئيس بيضا وايضا دول
اوروبيه اخرى مع السقف المرتفع لكياز
الامر لا يتعلق باحراج هذا واقع بانه في
بعض الدول الاوروبيه هناك مثلا ايطاليا
يوم امس تظاهرات كبيره تعارض استمرار
التقديم المساعدات
المتحده بعض الجمهوريين ايضا يقولون ان
الولايات المتحده قدمت اكثر ما ينبغي ولكن
همم
الاوروبيون بشكل امريكا
في اكثر من تفاوض مع بوتا اذا واحد ما
قررت قوات روسيه انسحابه من اوكرانيا
صابونينا يعني
روسيا كيف يمكن ان تفهم هذا النقاش كيف
يمكن ان تنظر الى الى هذا النقاش ما بين
الولايات المتحده واوكرانيا حول امكانيه
التفاوض او اظهار مرونه
بموضوع التفاوض
لوقف الحرب
مساء الخير نحن نشعر في روسيا بانه هناك
محاولات جسم نبض من قبل الامريكان حاليا
حول امكانيه ايجاد حلول للمواجهه في
اوكرانيا
وهذا
شيء جديد ولكنه مستمر خلال
الاسبوعين الاخرين لانه بالاضافه لمقالات
في واشنطن بوست هناك بعض التسريبات هناك
ايضا
لقاءات همم غير معلن عنها
وعبر الوسط عبر تركيا حسب علمي عبر
الامارات ايضا عبر دول اخرى واا على سبيل
المثال هناك منظر يومين كانت في مقاله همم
مستشار الصادق للبيت
والان محل سياسي معروفه تشارلز
وهمم هذا المقال للنظر ومهمه هو يتسائل هل
تستطيع اوكرانيا ان تنتصر على روسيا بدون
تدخل امريكا او تدخل منظمه حلف ناتو
المباشر في هذه الازمه
لا اوكرانيا لا تستطيع الانتصار على روسيا
هل امريكا هي مهتمه بهذا التدخل المباشر
في اوكرانيا الجواب ايضا لا امريكا لا
تريد مواجهه سافر همم روسيا هذا خطير جدا
ويتناقض مع مصالح امريكا مع الوضع الحالي
الاقتصادي والسياسي في دول الغرب
فاذا فاذا حان الوقت للجلوس على المفاوضات
ااا سؤال ثالث مهم هلا بقاء منطقه دنباس
وشبه جزيره القرم لدى روسيا يستحق التدخل
الامريكيا مباشره في هذه المواجهه ايضا
الجواب لا فاذا هناك كانه التلميحات انه
امريكا من ناحيتها ممكن ان توافق على بقاء
بعض الاقاليم لدى روسيا بما فيها شبه
جزيره القرم السؤال هل حكومه تكرانيه
مستعده همم ان توافق على هذا الشيء انا
اعرف انه القياده الروسيه مستعده على اقل
التفاوض حول هذا الموضوع هذه النقطه
بالتحديد التي كنت همم اطرحها على ضيفه
السيد قسطنطين ريشينكو سيد قسنطين همم
عندما همم تعلن اوكرانيا انها لا تريد
التفاوض الا اذا ابدت روسيا نيتها
الانسحاب او قبولها بالانسحاب من الاراضي
التي سيطرت عليها طب اذا اذا قبلت
بالانسحاب من كل الاراضي التي سيطرت عليها
ما فائده التفوق السؤال هنا التفاوض هو من
اجل الوصول الى حلول وسط هل اوكرانيا وهذا
ما ذكرته سيده الينا سبونينا هل اوكرانيا
مستعده للقبول بحلول وسط فيما يتعلق
باقليم دومباس وجزيره القرم
كما تعلمون
هناك معايير موجوده في العلاقات
لكن انا رايي انه ليس فقط اوكرانيا حيث
انه 80%
على
ان نهايه الحرب ينبغي ان تتحقق فقط عند
عند
الاحتلال الروسي ولكن لو لو عرفوا ان هناك
تبدا حربا ثم تقوم سلف جزء
ويعتبار ذلك
هذا امر خيالي جدا هنا من المهم جدا
بالنسبه للاستقرار اوروبا
التاكد بانه ايا كانت نتيجه الحرب ستعتمد
على مبا القانون الدولي فاذا ما دمرته اذا
دمرته اوكرانيا فانا كنت تدمرنا القانون
الدولي اذا وافقت على قبول مكاسب على
الاراضي تحقيقه روسيا فهذا يعني المستقبل
لنا بان كل شيء
مشكوك فيه وليس هناك اي شيء يمكن الاعتماد
عليه ونقطه اخرى من الذي
يصدق روسيا عند مفاوضات
انا فعلا
كبيره مع روسيا اين ذهبت هذه المعاهدات
اتفاقات كلها روسيا واستخدمت القوه
حتى اكثر صعوبه بالاعلام رسميا بانهم
وسوف
يظنون الى روسيا اراضي لحتى انهم ليس
يطمرون عليها حاليا فكيف يمكن نبدا اي نوع
من التفاعل مع اناس
هنا يصبح
عفونا يعني هنا يصبح الحديث يتعلق بموازين
القوى ومن الذي يستطيع ان يفرض الامر
الواقع على على الارض في ظل موازين القوى
القائمه ساعود اليك لكن هنا انتقل من جديد
الى سيد ويليام همم سيد ويليام عندما تقول
همم اداره انها همم تريد مرونه في او
اظهار مرونه اوكرانيه في التفاوض مع مع
روسيا
هل ااا يعني تقرض ذلك باستعداد روسي
لانسحاب كامل وهل الولايات المتحده مستعده
لان تنتظر طول الحرب حتى ااه يفرض على
روسيا الانسحاب الكامل من دون تدخل امريكي
من دون تداخل ومن دون تدخل اي دوله اخرى
هل هذا ممكن
يبدو انهم مستعدون لاستمرار بتقديم الدعم
العسكري لاوكرانيا
طالما ان ذلك
ان هذا الدعم بشكل فعال ويدي الى تحقيق
تقدم في الحرب وهو ما يحصل حاليا
والان حقيقه المعروف الان ان الجيش
الاوكراني اقوى من الجيش الروسي وهذا ما
لم يكن عليه الحال في بدايه الحرب
وبالتالي ليس هناك اي رغبه لدى واشنطن او
حتى في اوروبا
على اجباري اوكرانيا للتفاوض بطريقه
الدولي وهذا قد يسمح لروسيا بان تحتفظ
ببعض الاجزاء اوكرانيا وهذا ليس بالامر
الذي يمكن لولايات المتحده او ثانيه ان
تقبله لانه يرون ذلك يعتبر اهانه فاشره
للامن وهجوم المباشر على الامن الاوروبي
وبالتالي ف- اوكرانيا في حنه الى ابدت
ثورون في المفاوضات ستواصل دقيقه تقدم في
الساحات المعارك وهذا هو اهم عنصر سيد
ويليام هل هناك قناه على لدى الولايات
المتحده ان القوات الاوكرانيه همم قادره
على استعاده السيطره على مناطق اقليم
دومباس وحتى على على القرن حتى لو وضعناها
جانبا اقله على ال- ال- المقاطعات الثلاث
الاخرى همم هل هنا قناعه امريكيه بامكانيه
استعاده السيطره عليها
الجزيره الاخباريه التحدي التحدي من وجهه
نظر عسكريه ولكن بقيه اوكرانيا
و في شمال
[موسيقى]
مستمره وهناك امكانيه او قناه على لدى
الجانبين
باستعاده السيطره على على مناطق سيطرت
عليها روسيا وبالتالي
سيستبعد خيار المفاوضات او اظهار المرونه
ما رايك
انا دائما اقرا بدقه ما يكتبه سيد ويليام
كورتني واعرف انه اعتمادا على خبرته
السابقه كاسفير في دول الاتحاد السوفيتي
سابقا هو دائما يدعو للمساعدات الاكثر
لاوكرانيا ولكننا نعرف تماما بانه الوضع
في داخل امريكا وفي داخل
كونجرس لن يكن قريبا هكذا بعد الانتخابات
في نوفمبر وهناك جمهوريين همم هم يدعون
اللي تركيزها على داخل الامريكي وليس على
الملف الاوكراني فحتى همم
الراي العام هذا الطريق جارنا الله
الاخيره ويشير الى انهو الاستطلاع على همم
في صفوف الجمهوريين ايضا يشير الى انه همم
هذه الان ان تزداد انه على امريكا
اهتم بامورها الداخليه والاقتصاديه وليس
باوكرانيا كيف هو يقول سيد كرتني انه
الجيش الاوكراني يستطيع ان يتفوق على
الجيش الروسي هذا برايس مستحيل واذا
انقطعت هذه الامدادات من امريكا او حتى
اذا قل ذلك الامدادات فهذا سيكون مستحيل
اكتر سؤال هنا مطروح للسيد قسنطين سؤال
للاخير سيد قسنطين ماذا لو لم همم تجري
الرياح بما تشتهيه اوكرانيا يعني ماذا لو
لم تستطع اوكرانيا استعاده السيطره على
المناطق التي سيطرت عليها روسيا هل سيكون
هناك مجال غير التفاوض
كل الحروف
تنتهي اما بالتفاوض او بالاستسلام
الاستسلام خارج الموضوع ولا غير مقبول هو
والمفاوضات ممكن تبدا فقط عندما نتفق على
اسس الباندا التليفون
بدانا به فيلم اللقاء شفنا ما ماذا ارادت
الولايات المتحده منا لا تريد
تخلى عنه فقط
انتهى وقتنا عذرا للمقاطعه سيد قسنطيني
ريشينكو وزير الخارجيه الاوكرانيه السابق
من كيف شكرا لسفير ويليام كورتني من
واشنطن
والباحثه والمحلل السياسيه من موسكو الينا
شكرا للمتابعه والى اللقاء
[موسيقى]